bonsoir de versailles et merci d'être
avec nous cette interdiction de
l'obligation vaccinale au texas est une
façon comme nous l'expliquait l'instant
thomas bonnet d'attaqué politiquement
joe biden selon vous
oui au fond de la vaccination c'est une
question de santé publique
mais en réalité ça s'est transformé de
plus en plus dans un imac politique et
donc un marqueur partisane républicaine
aux marques des étapes rouge et ils
jouent avec les vies des gens même si je
suis contre l'obligation de se vacciner
il me semble comme on dit dans des
démocraties avec des libertés et c'est
un choix personnel mais un mais ces
politiques qui exige certes
impressionnable comme dans les grandes
sociétés aériennes nous donne des
hôpitaux se vacciner me semble
raisonnable et pourrait opposer à ces
politiques simplement pour les raisons
politiques c'est c est responsable c'est
conditionnables les états unis sont
connus pour être avoir souvent une
politique très très libérale 1 basée sur
la liberté individuelle on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans la gestion de la
pandémie la joe biden qui veut rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour 100
millions de travailleurs à ce que ce
n'est pas étonnant
oui donc en édition d'être une question
de santé publique est maintenant
question politique on a aussi les
questions légales et heureusement et
malheureusement c'est une système
fédéral et je vois ce tout ça comme
quentin quoique de fédéralisme dans le
caca faut ni fédéraliste dans certaines
cités il est l'égal de fumée marois me
dans les autres c'est illégal d'une
sortie s'est faite un autre de
prostitution deux autres têtes
prostitution est illégale et maintenant
avec les vaccinations avec les kobe en
grande variabilité entre les 6 4 et ça
c'est la cacophonie de fait de l'ésmsa
c'est une question légale je parle
d'elle n'a pas les moyens de forcer le
gouverneur des textes appliqués sont
politique fédérale mais avec les avions
il est possible parce que le transport
aérienne et sous le régime réglementaire
des gouvernements fedora mais dans les
autres domaines 1 le gouverneur de
tactis à la liberté de proposer ces
politiques de vaccination a obligé on
l'a vu les républicains veulent mener
des poursuites judiciaires au nom des
libertés individuelles comment
réagissent selon sondés des américains
parce que je le répète ils sont plutôt
attachés d'une manière générale alors
liberté ces américains comment
réagissent ils face à cette envie de
vaccination obligatoire de joe biden
ceux qui s'opposent il y a beaucoup de
loire numérique qui sont violées tout le
temps bloc contre les drogues les gens
utilisent les drogues est donc il y a
une résistance au niveau individuel donc
ces politiques collectives il y en coûte
de désobéir le loi mais si nos morts les
jeunes sont bien capables de faire les
dissidences civile d'une telle question
de vaccination
aux questions au delà de ce sujet de
vaccination obligatoire le texas on l'a
vu ces derniers temps devient quasiment
l'illustration
d'une fronde anti joe biden
antidémocrates on entendait d'ailleurs
certains invités venus du texas on dire
il ya une vraie rupture d'une certaine
amérique avec ce président qui semble
loin de leurs préoccupations
le président des élites de washington
des grandes villes démocrate est ce
qu'il ya un petit peu de de cela très se
joue aussi we prod le présidente
présidence donnant 30 on a vu les
gouverneurs démocrates des états comme
californie ou new york s'opposer aux
politiques nationales et maintenant
c'est le tour des républiques al de
faire le même démarche donc ce qui est
bien pour le châssis viennent pour un
chien et à et bien sûr john heileman
rassemble quelques institutionnels
inside the belt il a passé toute sa vie
à washington et le procès psion qu'il
sort d elie et n'est pas fausse
mais au contraire le politique des
meilleures habitudes et gouverneur de
floride eux le vrai le gouveneur opposé
cette politique en leur propre mal en
klaus et et c'est vrai finalement le
plein d'amis rage aux états-unis en a
sept cent mille morts aux etats unis
accostera d'amis il faut finalement
trouvé une solution pour se rassembler
les deux parties dans une politique
commune et
par des noirs on reprochait justement l
avènement de l'élection de joe biden à
trump d'avoir fracturé l'amérique la
diviser en deux camps
finalement la lumière de tous ces
développements est ce qu'on se dit
aujourd'hui joe biden fait-il mieux en
ce sens non ils décident ressembler les
deux côtés mais michael est devenu une
société polarisée
politiquement du monde le bol nous
verser deux mois ils sentent us dans nos
politiques ils ne sont pas à pratiquer
complètement désintéressé dans le parti
mais censé devenir une société
polarisée et durban ii n'a pas la
capacité de faire les lois bipartisane
au début j'ai aidé des choses de base
qu'il a promis et même avec son
expérience de travail avec mitch
mcconnell les produits républicaine au
congrès n'est pas un jour et travaille
avec les gouverneurs dans un système
faudra prendre ensemble impossible donc
les divisions sans pierre de plus en
plus et peut-être une fois une menace
extérieure pour unifier les américaines
laissant seul à 1 1 6 6 7 6 en voie de
développement on pourrait dire ça c'est
une démarche de dire si bilson se
produise pas mais les prochaines
élections ce sera sur un décisive de
voir si les modérés sont elles ou où
c'est plutôt les légendes extrême gauche
extrême droite qui occupe toutes les
places dans une saine pratique